The answer is that in general I would think that algorithm A would be preferable to algorithm B
because the running time of algorithm A is 3n² -n+10 and here we have 2ⁿ.
So just ask what the algorithm of Alice, this function here would grow very fast
if and increases, but of course this is only a very general statement.
So in general you have to be a bit more careful about choosing algorithms even if the running times
deviate like this because as we said before we are taking worst-case running time
so maybe the average-case running time of algorithm B is much better than of algorithm A
and also we might be dealing with very small inputs.
So if you would know that n for example does not get much bigger than 10,
then those 2 algorithms are almost equal or sometimes even algorithm B would be preferable,
but in general, if you don't have any other information, I would go with algorithm A
because the running time is much lower than the running time here as long as n is not very small.